Caption: hello everyone
Caption: okay hi on to our next talk we have uh
Caption: Christy medak
Caption: we'll be speaking about from imposter
Caption: life to imposter moments tips from a
Caption: psychologist turned to engineer so a
Caption: little bit about Christy
Caption: she's a psychologist turned software
Caption: engineer currently navigating her way
Caption: through the world of technology after a
Caption: short but intense journey of
Caption: self-learning Christy landed a job as an
Caption: associate engineer at vgw and started
Caption: passing along her knowledge as Mentor at
Caption: she codes Australia
Caption: six months later she got promoted to
Caption: engineer still battling imposter
Caption: feelings
Caption: she's feeling she's passionate about
Caption: helping others getting into Tech solving
Caption: exciting coding problems and cheese
Caption: okay thank you Christy
Caption: thank you very much
Caption: there are quite a few people in this
Caption: room
Caption: and probably also a lot of you who have
Caption: a lot more experience than me and can
Caption: probably deliver way better talks than
Caption: me
Caption: I don't even know why everybody's here
Caption: to listen to me in the first place
Caption: I feel like such a fraud
Caption: [Music]
Caption: he slides up at the moment so I'm just
Caption: gonna keep going
Caption: so can I get a hands up if anyone has
Caption: ever felt kind of similar like you feel
Caption: like you don't really belong you don't
Caption: deserve your success
Caption: oh that's good that's pretty much
Caption: everyone here nice that makes me feel
Caption: better
Caption: um so yeah for those of you uh who came
Caption: in late and missed the introduction my
Caption: name is Christy I am a psychologist who
Caption: is now currently a software engineer and
Caption: I'm going to talk about my journey into
Caption: Tech and kind of navigating this whole
Caption: new world feeling like an imposter and
Caption: while I'm talking I'm also going to
Caption: share a lot of my personal experiences
Caption: which I'm a little bit nervous about but
Caption: I do feel that
Caption: um sharing and normalizing and
Caption: acknowledging these feelings go a long
Caption: way to actually overcoming them
Caption: it might be one of the try one of the
Caption: different
Caption: sorry a little bit of a technical
Caption: malfunction here
Caption: a moment ago yeah I just tried a
Caption: different
Caption: that's looking much better
Caption: cool
Caption: so now you missed my really cool gift of
Caption: putting a hand up but that's all right
Caption: because everybody else put their hand up
Caption: so that's cool
Caption: so I want to give a big shout out to all
Caption: the sponsors because without them you
Caption: and I or wouldn't have been here today
Caption: and this event wouldn't have been
Caption: possible so thank you very much to all
Caption: of the sponsors
Caption: all right so I'm going to start off with
Caption: one of my personal stories when I
Caption: started joining the tech industry I felt
Caption: quite overwhelmed
Caption: um when I just like my first day there
Caption: was a lot of new things to learn there
Caption: was new languages to learn a new code
Caption: base to navigate all these new tools
Caption: that I had to learn about and it was
Caption: quite frankly a little bit
Caption: um much and especially also looking at
Caption: my colleagues who all seem to navigate
Caption: this really really well more often than
Caption: not I kind of felt like do I even belong
Caption: in this industry maybe I shouldn't have
Caption: done this
Caption: so what I felt and I'm still currently
Caption: regularly experiencing is the textbook
Caption: definition of imposter syndrome
Caption: and imposter syndrome can be defined as
Caption: feelings of self-doubt and personal
Caption: incompetence that persists despite your
Caption: education experience or accomplishments
Caption: um
Caption: so you might wonder what does it feel
Caption: like to have imposter feelings well if
Caption: you kind of feel like you are big Birds
Caption: trying to fit in with the Darth Vader
Caption: Darth Vader grew on the Death Star
Caption: that's when you can probably tell that
Caption: you have impossible feelings
Caption: um but Jokes Aside there are some common
Caption: imposter thoughts that are likely to
Caption: occur
Caption: um so let's have a look and see what
Caption: goes on in the mind of people with
Caption: imposter feelings
Caption: so you might feel like you are a fake
Caption: and you're going to be found out
Caption: sorry about that
Caption: you might feel that you actually don't
Caption: deserve your success and you may have
Caption: just gotten lucky
Caption: you may feel like you're not released
Caption: that special at all and you feel like if
Caption: you can do it everybody else can do it
Caption: or you may not be very good with praise
Caption: and just kind of like wave it off as
Caption: like oh I had a lot of help
Caption: or maybe you just think that they were
Caption: just being nice to you
Caption: but regardless what you're feeling it
Caption: turns out to be
Caption: um very very common within the tech
Caption: industry it's actually 58 of people who
Caption: experience imposter feelings currently
Caption: in their career and this includes people
Caption: from companies like Amazon Google and
Caption: Facebook
Caption: so this is a study that has been done by
Caption: blinds they have done a very very
Caption: scientific study where they send people
Caption: a question in their app and asked do you
Caption: have impulsive feelings yes or no I mean
Caption: it's very simple but um yeah as you can
Caption: see they they are interviewed a lot of
Caption: people in in a lot of different
Caption: companies that are quite familiar to
Caption: most of you I reckon and this is a graph
Caption: of these companies that have the highest
Caption: rates of imposter feelings so
Caption: rest assured you are not alone
Caption: but why is it such a common thing in
Caption: Tech why do so many people in our
Caption: industry feel like they're undeserving
Caption: of their success despite their obvious
Caption: Merit
Caption: well I can think of one thing
Caption: I don't know if anyone here has ever
Caption: tried to explain to their mom what it is
Caption: that they're doing without them zoning
Caption: out or kind of looking at you like
Caption: you're speaking in another language
Caption: but it's not just the people from
Caption: outside the industry it kind of like
Caption: happens within the industry as well I'm
Caption: sure a lot of you have heard stories of
Caption: um projects that have been pushed where
Caption: you like gave an estimate that it would
Caption: take four weeks six weeks and they would
Caption: push you to do it in four weeks
Caption: but then there's also
Caption: um
Caption: expectations that come from within so
Caption: for instance if you're a new starter in
Caption: the industry you may not really know
Caption: what you need to do in order to perform
Caption: in your industry
Caption: um or if you are more experienced
Caption: something like a promotion or new
Caption: responsibilities can trigger imposter
Caption: feelings as well
Caption: then there is also the fast pace that's
Caption: happening in the tech industry things
Caption: change a lot there's new languages all
Caption: the time there's new Concepts that you
Caption: need to learn all the time you have to
Caption: keep up otherwise you will be outdated
Caption: and the same kind of works for companies
Caption: in general you always have to try and do
Caption: the new thing to make your customers
Caption: happy otherwise they will go elsewhere
Caption: um and it also kind of happens to
Caption: yourself you just want to keep up you
Caption: want to do a good job as a new starter
Caption: you might even want to like rush into
Caption: things and make sure that you get up to
Caption: speed as soon as possible and in the
Caption: process you may end up being burnt out
Caption: um but we shouldn't talk about it right
Caption: because it's kind of embarrassing to
Caption: have these feelings and I'm probably the
Caption: only person who has it
Caption: and then there is also the part of like
Caption: some of us
Caption: this has literally happened to me today
Caption: I haven't had a single line it was great
Caption: um
Caption: yeah so one of the other things that can
Caption: cause imposter feelings as well is
Caption: especially from people from
Caption: underrepresented groups is that they
Caption: don't really have these people that they
Caption: can look up to they miss
Caption: um people with empathetic leadership
Caption: skills or um like just generally people
Caption: who look like them who've had success in
Caption: their workplace
Caption: and if things weren't already bad enough
Caption: in the tech industry of course we also
Caption: have been hit by this thing called covet
Caption: and covet has kind of made us work in in
Caption: different ways now we all have kind of a
Caption: new role and we have to get ready like
Caption: have to be ready to work from home and
Caption: some of you may have even been parenting
Caption: as well well I'm teaching while working
Caption: from home
Caption: so yeah lots have happened and lots of
Caption: things that can actually trigger your
Caption: imposter feelings
Caption: but despite what you're feeling is can
Caption: be quite nerve-wracking it's actually
Caption: pretty normal and having a little bit of
Caption: self-doubt is actually healthy because
Caption: it will push you to do better things to
Caption: become better to learn new things so you
Caption: shouldn't feel bad about it
Caption: the goal here is to not feel like an
Caption: imposter ever again
Caption: but to have the tools to talk yourself
Caption: down faster when you have an imposter
Caption: moment
Caption: so let's go back through those
Caption: expectations I'm sure many of you have
Caption: seen this one
Caption: um when I got promoted about six months
Caption: ago I felt like I didn't deserve it at
Caption: all I wasn't ready I still felt like I
Caption: had so much to learn and there was so
Caption: many other associates who were way more
Caption: prepared for this than me
Caption: um so yeah my expectations of where I
Caption: needed to be were where I thought I had
Caption: to be versus where I actually had to be
Caption: way out of whack because if I look at it
Caption: rationally I had met all those
Caption: requirements
Caption: um yeah so
Caption: well sorry kind of blanking here
Caption: yeah so I focus so hard on the things
Caption: that I didn't know that I kind of forget
Caption: how far I actually have come so far if
Caption: you look at me a year and a half ago the
Caption: only thing I was probably able to do was
Caption: write a line of python that said hello
Caption: world in a console and now I am working
Caption: as a software engineer full-time at a
Caption: company I am mentoring and guiding
Caption: people who are new to the industry or
Caption: new to the job and I am standing here
Caption: presenting for all of you so that should
Caption: probably count for something I guess
Caption: foreign
Caption: so yeah I appreciate the progress that
Caption: you have made so far but if you're
Caption: really struggling to do that there's
Caption: other ways that you can kind of like
Caption: uh focus on how far you've come and it's
Caption: mentoring others if you are able to
Caption: teach a New Concept to a person who's
Caption: like just starting out that's a really
Caption: good way to sort of gauge like oh I've
Caption: actually managed to learn this myself
Caption: quite well and I'm able to actually
Caption: teach this to other people
Caption: but if you are really really set on
Caption: looking forward please remember that
Caption: your career is a marathon and not a
Caption: Sprint
Caption: if you take a nice steady Pace like a
Caption: marathon runner you can learn all these
Caption: new skills and learn all these new
Caption: knowledge while
Caption: not really zooming past anything that's
Caption: important
Caption: and part of that is also to do with
Caption: setting appropriate goals
Caption: you want to be able to focus on the core
Caption: skills developing core skills and rather
Caption: than focusing on trying to learn
Caption: everything all at once which I'm sure is
Caption: a rabbit hole that many of us has fallen
Caption: into me included
Caption: and also stop comparing yourself to
Caption: others this is one that's very easy to
Caption: fall into as well you tend to kind of
Caption: forget that other people may have had
Caption: like a lot more experience than you
Caption: um so comparing yourself to someone else
Caption: who went through a way different Journey
Caption: or has been working in the industry for
Caption: a few years now doesn't really help
Caption: so instead try and look at them like
Caption: Role Models or turn to them for help
Caption: so it can really be helpful to share
Caption: your imposter feelings with others
Caption: because they will a lot of them will be
Caption: able to kind of like acknowledge that
Caption: they're probably experiencing the same
Caption: thing from time to time or have
Caption: experiences in the past
Caption: um and having these feelings of
Caption: knowledge can work quite well I can tell
Caption: you from experience
Caption: because um I share my feelings with my
Caption: manager
Caption: all the time
Caption: I can't I can't even count the number of
Caption: times that I've been in a one-on-one
Caption: being like I feel like I'm not
Caption: progressing fast enough and I need to
Caption: know more and I need to learn more and
Caption: blah and he's just always managed to
Caption: make me feel better and that's because
Caption: he has like all of this experience and
Caption: knowledge of like yeah he has
Caption: experienced the same kind of feelings
Caption: and he has seen similar things by
Caption: mentoring others as well so it's
Caption: incredibly helpful to have a mentor to
Caption: help you out with this sort of stuff
Caption: but you know might also be wondering
Caption: Christy weren't you a psychologist
Caption: you should probably have some cool
Caption: tricks up your sleeve right
Caption: I do okay but I want to give a little
Caption: bit of a disclaimer here
Caption: um because as a psychologist we are
Caption: really good at um
Caption: uh advising other people and helping
Caption: guiding other people but when it comes
Caption: to ourselves those rules all of a sudden
Caption: don't seem to apply anymore
Caption: which is why I'm still having imposter
Caption: feelings
Caption: but there are um specifically two
Caption: exercises that I wanted to share with
Caption: you all that have been really helpful
Caption: for myself but also um clients that I
Caption: have treated in the past with similar
Caption: issues and these are exercises that are
Caption: part of cognitive behavioral therapy and
Caption: I will really do a deep dive into that
Caption: because I could do a whole different
Caption: talk about that but I will give a brief
Caption: overview of these exercises and I have
Caption: added a QR code for you to scan so you
Caption: can find some worksheets related to them
Caption: as well and you can look it up yourself
Caption: so the first one is cognitive
Caption: restructuring
Caption: oh everybody's putting up their phone
Caption: that's cool
Caption: and cognitive restructuring is a way to
Caption: really get to the root of why you are
Caption: having this imposter feeling in the
Caption: first place and how you came to believe
Caption: them
Caption: so you're kind of using this technique
Caption: called Socratic questioning where you
Caption: just challenge the thought that you're
Caption: having at the moment you might ask
Caption: yourself questions like is this thought
Caption: based on emotions or facts do I can I
Caption: think of any facts that actually support
Caption: this thought that I'm having or can I
Caption: think of any facts that
Caption: um support the fact that I that it's not
Caption: true what I'm thinking and it's those
Caption: kinds of questions that will help you
Caption: um kind of like get to the bottom of
Caption: this in a slightly more objective way
Caption: which have been quite helpful for me
Caption: and the next exercise is called
Caption: dysfunctional thought record
Caption: it's the same QR Code by the way so you
Caption: don't have to scan it again if you
Caption: already have it
Caption: this functional thought record really
Caption: helps you find out what triggers your
Caption: imposter thought it asks you to write
Caption: down things like the time and date of
Caption: your thoughts what the thought is how
Caption: you would rate its intensity and
Caption: emotions that come with it but the most
Caption: important part of this one is that you
Caption: think of alternative thoughts that could
Caption: actually be more positive or helpful to
Caption: replace your negative one
Caption: well now so far I have been giving you a
Caption: lot of tips to handle impulsive Feelings
Caption: by yourself and this is probably a lot
Caption: of the stuff that you can find online as
Caption: well but one of the things that I find
Caption: is really important here is that
Caption: leadership can actually have an
Caption: important role in helping other people
Caption: with impossive feelings too
Caption: and so leaders why should you help out
Caption: others with impulsive feelings because
Caption: it actually turns out in research that
Caption: imposter feelings impact the performance
Caption: of both the individual and the team it's
Caption: actually correlated with job poor job
Caption: performance poor job satisfaction and
Caption: burnout
Caption: so it's important to learn and to
Caption: identify impulsive feelings in others
Caption: [Music]
Caption: I need a little bit of help with this
Caption: one
Caption: so impossible feelings can be quite
Caption: complex and sometimes not even that
Caption: obvious your team member may seem
Caption: fatigued or disinterested or um maybe
Caption: just completely the opposite and really
Caption: on top of things and and going Beyond
Caption: above and beyond to try and just do the
Caption: right thing and and
Caption: um
Caption: so that they can prove their worth
Caption: um but what about the high performer who
Caption: tends to avoid these like more tricky
Caption: projects
Caption: or the person who doesn't put their hand
Caption: up for a promotion
Caption: or the person who look seems to be
Caption: uncomfortable with praise and kind of
Caption: just like waves it off as luck or uh
Caption: something that they got a lot of help
Caption: from other people or maybe they just
Caption: appear really skeptical when you
Caption: encourage them to do something new
Caption: you also want to stay attuned to
Caption: negative self-talk things like oh silly
Caption: question or had it really terrible on
Caption: that presentation
Caption: or someone could probably someone better
Caption: should probably be doing this or someone
Caption: else should probably be doing this are
Caption: really good examples of self-deprecating
Caption: talk and can be harmful for a team
Caption: members performance as well
Caption: but to be fair it can be pretty hard to
Caption: walk up to a manager and talk about
Caption: these kinds of feelings right so as a
Caption: manager you want to be if you want to be
Caption: able to have these kinds of
Caption: conversations you want to show empathy
Caption: and vulnerability and that means that
Caption: you might have to open up about your
Caption: imposter feelings first before someone
Caption: else feels comfortable enough to come to
Caption: you
Caption: so when a team member does come to you
Caption: it's important that you acknowledge
Caption: their feelings and maybe share one of
Caption: your own experiences oh I need to wrap
Caption: this up apparently quick you want to
Caption: organize appropriate mentoring
Caption: and this doesn't necessarily have to be
Caption: a senior person this can be anyone on
Caption: your team who maybe have slightly more
Caption: experience than the person who's just
Caption: joining
Caption: you want to get feedback from team
Caption: members about the work environment so
Caption: one thing that my new VP of engineering
Caption: recently did was just have a chat with
Caption: all of us and ask questions like what do
Caption: I do when you're grumpy should I just
Caption: come up to you leave you alone send you
Caption: a message how do you like to to get
Caption: praised do you like that one-on-one am I
Caption: is it okay if I share this stuff in a
Caption: team things like that can all go a long
Caption: way to make a person more comfortable
Caption: with these sort of situations
Caption: and you want to of course give praise to
Caption: and celebrate wins with your entire team
Caption: in the way that they all feel
Caption: comfortable with
Caption: so quick recap
Caption: um impossible feelings and dealing with
Caption: them can be quite hard but if you can
Caption: acknowledge them that is the first step
Caption: towards actually dealing with them and
Caption: over time you'll notice that your
Caption: moments will last will be shorter and
Caption: shorter and you'll have less and less of
Caption: them
Caption: you can do things like managing
Caption: all these things that I just previously
Caption: mentioned that's what you can do
Caption: laughs
Caption: but I do really wanted to say this
Caption: before I step off stage and give it to
Caption: someone else it is okay to ask for
Caption: professional help as well dealing with
Caption: imposter syndrome can be hard and to be
Caption: honest I have actually have seen a
Caption: counselor myself to deal with some
Caption: similar kind of issues and I found that
Caption: it's been really really helpful for me
Caption: uh well thank you unfortunately I can't
Caption: take any questions but feel free to come
Caption: up to me after the talk or reach out on
Caption: LinkedIn thank you all so much for
Caption: listening
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Applause]